again
this this looks inward but it's not
inward this is outward okay
part of the mysticism of your art is
this reconciliation of the dichotomy
okay
part of that is
out you must learn how to make outward
go in and inward go out
okay so you're doing this you're not
this is not going in
this is going out
but i'm turning inside of it turned
inside of it
[Music]
well
this is not going
out
that's wrong
this is going in
but i'm turning inside of it okay so
it's not this hand is going in
and this hands going out that's not it
pay attention that is
biomechanically unsound
okay
so
this one is going in
but i'm going to turn as it as it's
doing it
i'm going to turn as it's doing it
and it starts to go out
that's why he can't come back in it's
going this way
the don't start changing it
this one out
this one is
but i turn inside of it
and he'll hit you'll hit that
wow
you're gonna be locked in his butt
don't open it up
[Music]
you're not going around his energy
you're gonna
check the integrity of your outwardness
by pushing into it
okay now now uh shorten the movements
right there
try to try to take your arms your arms
[Music]
so
she
okay so this this drill is just to keep
that outward integrity to what you're
doing okay
uh
but as you go into the throw
it's important if he's doing the back
right fall
then he has to be in the back inward
kazushi
okay
so
you have to figure out
how to get that you see so if you if
you're doing a multi
you're not going to do it like this
so you have to turn him turn him there
it is
same thing goes on 10 pod okay
so you go like this yeah that's not it
so take card you have to be
way in the back
oh
there it is
okay
we can't be here
on the
[Music]
same thing on
we're up
here
get the tilt
get the kazushi pattern
go
okay so now that pressure that we were
using to test the grounding and the
outward integrity of the
tencon we're going to uh
void okay and then we're going to be
able to enter
point
what you're looking for is that you're
not pushing them away
since i'm not holding that integrity he
should keep coming in
oh
[Music]
three
oh
[Music]
let's go okay so you have to draw a
clear distinction between him hitting
that
and then you he hits it but you yield it
out of the way okay now when you're here
it's not back to him hitting that and
that's what knocks him down
he his energy
you have to spiral around so as he as he
hits it it has to come around
do you see
just like
so you can't enter if he's still going
that way that's just overpowering he's
falling already he's he's falling
well he's going to come in
and i'm going to do the circle on his
head he's already falling and i'm not
entering yet i enter with him to keep
contact with him and to attack his face
which is already compromised because his
upper body is following do you
understand
you're not here
and then
boom that's not it
it was already falling there's no energy
up here anymore okay what the arm is
doing at the top
is keeping the base attackable
okay so he's coming around
and imagine his energy's going that way
and it's keeping his base attackable
so
if that's the case
then i can do this same technique
right there
i'm not on his head see i don't need the
distal end of the levers okay i'm not on
his head so
almost there and i yield that
here he comes around
so i'm now
on his torso
now what notice hey
the torso
gives me the same triangle here's where
i do the reconciliation
locks the same body block and like lets
the stance be attackable
so you're doing the same technique
[Music]
so
let's try